Speaker 1: All right. Why don't we speak to a
couple of other people, right? I mean, we're here.
We sort of we sort of might as well.
Why don't we go to Garran from Dallas?
Yes, I know.
Speaker 5: Hey, so yes,
I'm a physician here in Dallas and I've just
been, you know, there's an your show probably
for the past year and I've really appreciated your
kind of rhetoric and take on the on the just the
whole coronavirus pandemic in general. I guess my
my thoughts and my question to you is, you know,
you know, as someone you know, your family kind
of comes to you with advice as a physician,
you know, and things like that. And one of
the things that's been really kind of tough
for me going forward as a physician as well,
you know, I have this very pro vaccine pro,
you know, maskin standpoint. And people
want to reach out to you and say, well,
what about these other problems that I
have? And, you know, it's the kind of
I don't know if other physicians have this kind
of dilemma, but it's trying trying to how do you
how do you trust some information that I tell
you, but not other information that I tell you?
And it's like a box and it's kind of broken the
glass box for me on a lot of people, you know, and
especially friends and family. I'm just curious
if you've had that kind of interactions or
you're kind of those revelations of certain
people, it's like, how can you not understand
this pretty good data that we have? You know, it's
I don't know if you got that kind of experience.
Speaker 1: I have I have family. Now, let
me ask you this. What's your specialty?
Speaker 5: So I'm orthopedic surgeon, so,
Speaker 1: OK, so it's not directly related to
immunology or epidemiology, right? So in other
words, people come to you and they say, sir,
you know, my knees bothering me and then you give
them you, whatever you talk about it, and then
they implicitly trust you. But then when you say,
hey, we I'm a doctor, I know how to read a medical
study, get the vaccine, it is really effective
all of a sudden then they don't they don't believe
you. They're skeptical of your your thought.
Speaker 5: That's yeah. That's you know,
all those people become pretty experts in the face
of certain data, you know, but then, you know,
obviously they, you know, unequivocally trust
my, you know, input on their hip arthritis or,
you know, whatever you want to call it.
So sure. Yeah. It's just. Yeah. You know,
I don't know if other physicians or
other people have experienced that.
Speaker 1: They have I know an
emergency, a pediatric emergency doctor
who has some antibiotics, people floating
around in his family. And he's talked about how
they come to me with questions about their babies.
And then all of a sudden I'm saying we all need to
get the vaccine and they it just doesn't convince
them they don't care. Yeah, yeah. Hey, listen,
while I have you on the phone, brief orthopedic
consult. Yeah. So, you know, I'm in my mid
30s now and I'm getting a little bit of sort
of crunching, crackling in my knees. And when
you Google this, it's everything from you need a
new leg, too. Don't worry about it. Right. Like,
how should I be thinking about that?
Speaker 5: Yeah. So, you know, I mean I mean,
you're in your mid 30s, I think. Right. So, you
know, everyone everyone kind of gets arthritis as
we age, you know, but there's a ton of things that
can cause knee pain, you know, meniscal problems.
You know, I think I've heard you say you're kind
of an avid runner and things like that. So people.
Speaker 1: Oh, no, we're losing you
right at the moment of the diagnosis.
Speaker 5: Oh, yeah. Can you hear me?
Speaker 1: Yeah, I'm thinking you were
saying running can aggravate this.
Speaker 5: Yeah. I mean, you know,
so it kind of depends on your symptoms.
The crunching, popping things you're kind
of describing doesn't sound like it could be
meniscal related or. Yeah. You know, hopefully
not early arthritis for you, but probably not.
Speaker 1: So I actually have this birth defect
called this meniscus in one knee.
Speaker 5: And that's that
would probably probably be related to
some of the things you're referring to.
Speaker 1: Is this called meniscus typically
bi lateral or it can be just on one side.
Speaker 5: You can definitely get
it bilaterally, but there are cases,
you know, unilaterally can be as well. So, I
mean, is that the knee that's popping on you?
Speaker 1: It's not. That's the interesting thing.
Speaker 5: It's not. Well, you know, some people
when they're kids have this going meniscus,
but they never really bothers them. You know,
the main symptom they'll get is catching symptoms,
locking, popping, that kind of thing. Right.
Some people have it and just never really have
pain. So it's not bothering you then? There's
really nothing much to do about it.
Speaker 1: So like it is, you know,
when you start to think about it, I'm like,
here's my knee unstable. Am I am I having a
bigger issue here? But it might just be
that I'm thinking about it, you know?
Speaker 5: Yeah, absolutely.
Speaker 1: Wow. So for the most part,
I can keep the leg for now.
Speaker 5: Yeah. I mean,
I don't think we're going to amputate it just yet
on you, but, you know, let me know how it's going
and we can we can take it off if we need to.
Speaker 1: We'll take it from there,
OK. All right. Good. OK, Dr. Guaran, thank you so
much. Thanks, David. All right. Great call. Wow.
By the way, if there's a podiatrist in the
audience, I also have other questions. So if
you could call in, I would really appreciate a
consult on that as well. Let's go next to Alvaro
from Tulsa, Oklahoma. You're on the air. Alvira.
Really just barely sounds like you're underwater.
Speaker 2: I mean, they want someone
Speaker 1: who has no it's no better you.
All right. I mean, it just I just can't do that
today, it's too busy of a day to start with that.